you know dre has been in the studio
working on
the detox in 13 million iterations of
the detox for the last hour dr dre is a
stickler how many how many like have you
heard any of that music and were you
asked to be on any of the records that
we probably will never end up hearing
but like was were you ever at at all
point a part of that creative process
since day one
since day one oh yeah
how great is the music
because i'm sure whatever you heard will
probably never even appearing but like i
mean i hope i'm wrong i heard three or
four detoxes
you know it's like but dr dre
you know he's he's a
perfectionist
that's why all his records are just
different every time they hit a peak
they go somewhere with something
different dr dre
it's a perfectionist you know he's
you know you wait and you wait but when
you get it
it's worth it oh boy is it you know what
i'm saying
and so you know with dr dre
i mean [ __ ] man he got so much in that
vault
you know
classics but you know dr dre
is something he's looking for him when
he finds it
i just hope i just hope we like like we
get an album
where we hear you and snoop and dads and
exhibit and
yeah has so many that he
has created so many
like superstars and of course
artists
that people want to hear like that
you know i think it's kind of difficult
by the way
well he did a great job putting the the
compton album together yeah that album
doesn't get talked about enough that was
a great body of work but i just like i'm
just always like man like you know i
remember before
that chronic album the last chronicle
he put out the aftermath
yeah the aftermath uh compilation we've
been there done that
and then he dropped the chronic
this time he dropped compton
that's fair so you know nice comparison
so you know what's gonna happen
okay
well we'll be waiting